THAT IS THE FOCUS OF A VERY
IMPORTANT NEWS BREAKING
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT, HUGE BREAKING
NEWS TONIGHT.
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU IT’S COMING.
IT IS NOW HERE.
STUNNING REPORTING TONIGHT
FROM SARA CARTER THAT WE ARE
CONFIRMING WITH OUR SOURCES.
CLASSIFIED DOJ DOCUMENTS
THAT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
NOW REVIEWING IT SHOWS
WIDESPREAD AND EXTENSIVE
FISA ABUSES AGAINST THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND WE HAVE NAMES.
NOW, HERE IS HOW IT ALL WENT
DOWN.
AT THE LAST MINUTE THE
HOUSE, THEY FINALLY GOT
LITERALLY WITHIN AN HOUR,
THEIR SUBPOENA REQUESTS
APPROVED BY THE DOJ.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WERE
ABLE TO GET THEIR HANDS ON
ALL THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
NOW, AT THE LAST MINUTE, ROD
ROSENSTEIN TRIED TO STOP IT
BY GOING INTO PAUL RYAN’S
OFFICE.
PAUL RYAN WOULD HAVE NONE OF
IT.
NOW, IT IS MORE DISTURBING
THAN WE EVER THOUGHT.
AND AT THIS HOUR OUR SOURCES
ARE TELLING US THAT THE
ABUSIVE POWER IS FAR BIGGER
THAN WATERGATE.
REMEMBER, WATERGATE WAS A
THIRD RATE BREAK.
IN WE’RE TALKING ABOUT
TONIGHT IS THE SYSTEMATIC
ABUSE OF POWER, THE
WEAPONIZING OF THOSE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE, AND THE
SHREDDING OF OUR FOURTH
AMENDMENT CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS THAT PROTECT AUGUST
ALL OFUS AGAINST UNLAWFUL SEARCH
AND SEIZURE.
IT IS COMPLICATED BUT
SIMPLE.
WE WILL BREAK IT DOWN FOR
NEW A WAY THAT I HOPE IS
EASY TO UNDERSTAND.
GO BACK TO THE WATERGATE
COMPARISON FOR A MINUTE.
WE HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WHO TRIED TO COVER UP THE
LEAD UP TO AN ELECTION.
THEY BROKE IN.
THEY STOLE THINGS THEY
SHOULDN’T HAVE STOLE FROM
THE OPPOSITION.
WHAT WE’RE TALKING ABOUT
TONIGHT IS AN ABUSE OF THE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE USE TO
SPY ON PEOPLE, EXCEPT THOSE
TOOLS WERE USED AGAINST AN
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE, AND A
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
AND HIS ENTIRE TEAM.
AND IT WAS DONE NOT ONLY
UNDER FALSE PRETENSES, BUT
WITH THE HELP OF HILLARY
CLINTON.
SHE BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER THAT THEY FILLED
WITH RUSSIAN LIES,
PROPAGANDA, SALACIOUS
DETAILS THAT WERE NEVER
TRUE.
AND THAT DOSSIER WAS
CORROBORATED, WE NOW KNOW,
BY A LONG-TIME CLINTON ALLY
AND SYCOPHANT:  NOW, HERE
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE’RE
GOING TO LEARN AN AWFUL LOT
ABOUT IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION.
THEY ARE THE HIGHEST RANKS
OF THE INDICTMENT OF JUSTICE
IN YOUR FBI.
AND TONIGHT WE CAN CONFIRM
THAT THE TRUMP HATING,
CLINTON-LOVING, FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK AND HIS
MISTRESS, FBI LAWYER LISA
PAGE, THEY ARE AT THE NEXUS
OF EVERYTHING AND THERE IS
SO MUCH MORE INFORMATION
COMING.
NOW, AT THE END OF ALL OF
THIS, WE’RE GOING TO LEARN
AN AWFUL LOT BEYOND ANY
SHADOW OF A DOUBT THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, ROBERT
MUELLER AND HIS BAND OF
DEMOCRATIC WITCH-HUNTERS
NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED AND THEY NEED TO
BE DISBANDED IMMEDIATELY.
NOW, HERE’S WHY STRZOK AND
PAGE ARE CONNECTED TO
EVERYTHING.
WHAT WE’RE LEARNING TONIGHT
IS THAT THESE TWO
TRUMP-HATING INDIVIDUALS,
THEY ARE AT THE HEART AND
SOUL AND CENTER OF IT ALL.
REMEMBER, WE STILL HAVE 9600
TEXTS OF THEIRS BETWEEN EACH
OTHER THAT WE HAVEN’T SEEN
YET.
AND WE’RE EXPECTING THAT
SOME OF THEM WILL BE
RELEASED TOMORROW.
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE
LEARNED SO FAR ABOUT STRZOK
AND PAGE IS NOW BEGINNING TO
MAKE SENSE.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
THEY CALLED TRUMP AN IDIOT,
A LOATHE SOME HUMAN AND SAID
F TRUMP.
AND BY THE WAY THE MEANING
BY BEHIND THIS PARTICULAR
TEXT MESSAGE IS NOW TONIGHT
COMING INTO CLEAR FOCUS.
REMEMBER STRZOK, HE WROTE
HIS MISTRESS, PAGE, I
WANTING TO BELIEVE THE PATH
THAT YOU THREW OUT FOR
CONSIDERATION IN ANDY’S
OFFICE THAT THERE IS NO WAY
HE GETS ELECTED, BUT I’M
AFRAID WE CAN’T TAKE THAT
RISK.
IT’S LIKE AN INSURANCE
POLICY IN THE UNLIKELY EVENT
YOU DIE BEFORE YOU’RE 40.
NOW, WE BELIEVE HERE AT FOX
THAT ANDY, MENTIONED IN THAT
TEXT, IS THE FBI DEPUTY
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE.
AND THIS TEXT MESSAGE WAS
SENT ON AUGUST THE 15TH OF
2016.
THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL TIME
FRAME AND HERE’S WHY.
AROUND THE EXACT SAME TIME
THAT STRZOK AND PAGE ARE
TALKING ABOUT THEIR
INSURANCE POLICY, WELL, THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ARE GOING TO THE
FISA COURT TO GET A WARRANT
ON CARTER PAGE.
STAY WITH ME.
THEY ARE USING CARTER PAGE
AS A PRETEXT TO REALLY SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND NOW IT IS TRANSPARENT TO
ALL OF US WHAT STRZOK WAS
SAYING TO PAGE WHEN THEY
SPOKE ABOUT THE INSURANCE
POLICY WITH ANDY WE BELIEVE
ANDREW MCCABE IN THAT TEXT
MESSAGE, NEEDING THAT
INSURANCE POLICY.
NOW, EVERYONE SEEMS TO
FORGET LISA PAGE IS A KEY
LEGAL COUNSELOR FOR MCCABE.
SEE HOW IT ALL TIES
TOGETHER?
AND, LISTEN, WHEN THEY ARE
SENDING THE TEXT MESSAGES
ABOUT AN INSURANCE POLICY,
THEY ARE ALSO GOING TO THE
FISA COURT.
NOW, SOURCES ARE TELLING US
TONIGHT THAT THE FIRST TIME
THEY TRIED TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE
WAS IN THE SUMMER.
IT WAS DENIED.
THEN THE SECOND TIME THEY
TRIED TO GET IT IN THE EARLY
FALL, THEY USED THE PHONY
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER.
AND THIS TIME THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL FOR ONE REASON.
THE FAKE NEWS DOSSIER PUT
THE REQUEST OVER THE TOP.
IT WAS THE FINAL NAIL IN THE
COFFIN TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT OUT THERE AGAINST
TRUMP.
NOW, YOU CAN FORGET ABOUT
THE REPORTING ABOUT GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS RUNNING HIS
MOUTH AT A NIGHTCLUB TO AN
AUSTRALIAN DIPLOMAT.
ANY LAWYER IS GOING TO TELL
YOU THAT THAT FOUR-WAY
HEARSAY, THAT’S NEVER GOING
TO HOLD UP IN COURT.
HEARSAY DOESN’T HOLD UP IN
COURT.
SO BACK TO CARTER PAGE AND
THE FISA WARRANT ON HIM.
IT’S A VERY IMPORTANT
VARIETY OF THINGS HAPPENING
HERE.
AT THAT POINT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THEY SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS TOTALLY FALSE, FULL OF
SALACIOUS RUSSIAN LIES.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN SUSPECT
ON ITS FACE VALUE.
NOW FUSION GPS, THEY NEVER
EVEN VERIFIED WHAT WAS IN
THAT DOSSIER, NEVER TRIED.
BECAUSE THEY TRUSTED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO THEY
HIRED WHO PUT IT ALL
TOGETHER.
THE SAME CHRISTOPHER STEELE
WOULD REPORTEDLY, YOU KNOW,
PAY RUSSIANS TO GET
INFORMATION.
AND BY HIS VERY NATURE,
THINK ABOUT IT, HE HAS A
FORMER MI-6 GUY.
HE WAS HIGHLY SKILLED IN
DECEPTION.
SO TONIGHT’S SOURCES WERE
FAMILIAR WITH THIS
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ONLY
CONGRESS CAN SEE IT RIGHT
NOW.
THEY ARE TELLING ME THAT
IT’S A CASE OF SHOW ME THE
MAN AND I WILL SHOW YOU THE
CRIME.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW THAT YOU ARE UP TO SPEED
ON THAT PART.
WE HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
FOR KEY PEOPLE INVOLVED.
NOW, WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT
ALL OF THESE TOP OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
KNEW AND WHEN THEY FOUND
OUT.
AND EXACTLY HOW THEY WERE
INVOLVED IN SPYING ON AN
OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN AND AN
INCOMING PRESIDENT.
NOW, OUR QUESTIONS DON’T END
THERE.
WHAT DID HILLARY CLINTON
KNOW?
HER CAMPAIGN KNOW?
THE DNC THAT SHE CONTROLLED
KNOW?
WE KNOW THEY PAID FUSION
GPS, WHAT, 12 BILLION PLUS
DOLLARS TO PUT THIS PHONY
DOSSIER TOGETHER.
DID SHE KNOW THIS WAS
HAPPENING AND WHEN DID SHE
KNOW IT?
WHAT DID PRESIDENT OBAMA
KNOW?
WAS HE BRIEFED ABOUT THE
DOSSIER BEFORE THE ELECTION?
NOW, WE BELIEVE HE WAS.
TO SUM IT ALL UP, CLINTON
FIXED THE PRIMARY, REMEMBER,
AGAINST BERNIE SANDERS, THEN
PETER STRZOK AND JAMES
COMEY, WELL, THEY FIXED THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HER
EMAILS BY EXONERATING HER
BEFORE EVEN INVESTIGATING
THAT PARTICULAR CASE.
THAT ALLOWED CLINTON TO STAY
TIME STRZOK HIS MISTRESS,
LISA PAGE, DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR MCCABE SEEMED TO BE
ON A MISSION, AN INSURANCE
POLICY MISSION TO DESTROY
TRUMP.
INSURANCE POLICY IN CASE GOD
FORBID HE WINS, WE DON’T
THINK IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT’S CLEAR THEY WERE USING
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE AND A FISA
WARRANT TO HAVE A BACKUP
PLAN IN CASE HILLARY LOST.
THIS IS FAR WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
THIS IS AN ABUSE OF
SURVEILLANCE AND
INTELLIGENCE TO WIN AN
ELECTION.
A MASSIVE ABUSE OF POWER.
AND IT WAS ALL DONE BY JUST
A FEW PEOPLE WHO THINK AND
THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER
THAN YOU ABOUT WHO SHOULD BE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS IS ONLY THE TIP OF THE